what's  wrapping rebels i decided to come to the  happiest place on earth  but i accidentally ended up in epcot  that's experimental city of tomorrow  welcome everybody time to ski  this is epcot center  [Music]  health tip if you drink you can't feel  feelings anymore  and forget you can't see your kids  all right rebels we're about to see in  an extra dimension  and guess what you guys just have to  deal with it  [Music]  wow  [Music]  what says canada more than martin short  so he  i know somebody's playing music but i  want to make it all about me  [Music]  [ __ ] skittles  [Music]  is  hello boy table it's almost camera today  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  all right rebels we had fun at epcot we  learn how to use our imagination  and how to fly through space see you  guys next time and somebody tell my kids  i said hi